hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar far field optical nano
thermometry via individual luminescent
nanoparticles
i am antonina salcido of labyrinths and
i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by andor
to learn more visit andor.oxinst.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
andrea pikel assistant professor at the
department of mechanical engineering at
the university of rochester andrea you
may now begin your presentation
well thank you for the introduction so
once again my name is andrea pickell and
i'm an assistant professor in the
department of mechanical engineering at
the university of rochester
one area that my research group really
focuses on is developing new techniques
to measure temperature at the nanoscale
and in particular a lot of our work
focuses on using individual luminescent
nanoparticles to measure temperature at
the nanoscale
and so that's the work that i will be
talking about today
all right so i'll begin by talking about
some of the reasons why we need
nanoscale thermometry
and so one reason that we're probably
all familiar with is that our electronic
devices things like laptops and
smartphones are very prone to
overheating and we experience that in a
macroscopic sense in our everyday life
but the origins of these problems are
really at the nanoscale and that's
because transistors now have feature
sizes on the order of tens of nanometers
and so hot spots have shrunk to the
nanoscale as well
another area where heat transfer is
important is in a number of energy
applications and here one particularly
important example is lighting which
accounts for about six percent of our
total energy use here in the us
and as we've shifted away from
incandescent light bulbs to leds the
thermal challenges associated with
lighting have shifted to the nanoscale
and that's because leds are
semiconductor devices that contain many
thin layers some of which are only a few
nanometers thick
and although leds are a lot more
efficient than incandescent bulbs they
still waste typically at least 10 of
their input energy as heat and an led
operating above its maximum rate of
temperature can suffer huge performance
and reliability losses
even a 10 degree increase can cut the
lifetime of an led in half
on the other hand there are also
applications where rather than being
parasitic localized heating can actually
be desirable if it's carefully
controlled
one example here is thermal cancer
therapies where nanoparticles are
embedded in cancerous cells and then a
laser is used to selectively heat the
nanoparticles with the goal of then
killing the cancerous cells by heating
them while leaving the healthy tissue
intact
another place where controlled localized
heating can be beneficial is in some
next generation data storage
technologies one example here is heat
assisted magnetic recording where
localized heating is used to temporarily
change the magnetic properties of the
recording medium and another example is
phase change memory where joule heating
is used to switch a nanoscale amount of
phase change material
between two different states
and so next to understand how
specifically the inability to measure
temperature limits some of these
technologies i'll discuss a couple
examples in more detail
key to cystic magnetic recording or
hammer is as i said a next generation
hard drive technology and it's expected
to more than double storage densities
the key idea behind hammer is to
plasmonically excite this gold
lollipop shaped structure known as the
near field transducer and then couple
energy from the 30 nanometer peg across
across a nanoscale gas and into the
recording medium below
and this energy then locally heats the
recording medium which temporarily and
lowers its coercive coercivity and
ultimately allows for smaller bit size
and higher storage densities
but one challenge for hammer is that
it's known that rather than heating the
recording medium instead significant
overheating of the 30 nanometer peg can
occur
and degradation of this peg can cause
entire hammer drives to fail
and so again
it's thought that the cause of this
degradation is overheating right now
there's no existing technique that can
measure the temperature of the hammer
peg during operation to verify whether
this is actually the case
phase change memory is another next
generation data storage technology and
here the idea is to use joule heating to
switch a nanoscale amount of a phase
change material typically a calcagenide
glass between a resistive amorphous
state and a conductive crystalline state
and the way that this works is that to
go from crystalline to amorphous the
phase change material is heated above
its melting temperature and then quickly
quench to lock in the amorphous state
and to go from amorphous to crystalline
the phase change material is heated
above what's known as the
crystallization temperature which is
lower than the melting temperature
and then held there until it
recrystallizes
it's known that the crystallization
temperature of these nanoscale amounts
of phase change material can differ
significantly from the bulk value
some estimate suggests by hundreds of
degrees
but again right now there's no existing
technique that can measure this
nanoscale crystallization temperature in
phase change memory devices
so stepping back for a minute and
starting to think a bit more broadly
about these examples that i've just
discussed there are certain recurring
themes that start to emerge in terms of
the types of systems where we'd like to
be able to measure temperature at the
nanoscale
and so one theme is that we'd like to be
able to measure the temperature across
stacks of thin films whether that's in
the active region of leds or other
optoelectronic devices or in the
recording medium and heatsink layers
underneath the hammer peg
another theme is that we'd like to be
able to measure the temperature of
nanoscale hotspots
like the hammer peg itself or the
unknown crystallization temperature in
these phase change memory devices
and so today i'll focus on the nano
scale hotspot since that's really the
particular application that the
technique i'll be talking about today is
best suited to address
before getting into some of the
experimental techniques
i want to discuss some of the
more fundamental motivation for
nanoscale thermometry techniques and
what i mean by that is we might ask you
know couldn't we just develop very
sophisticated models or calculations in
order
to determine what the temperature of
these nanoscale hotspots could be
it turns out that one major challenge
here is that the classical laws of heat
transfer that say you might learn in an
undergraduate course don't always hold
up at the nanoscale
and we can understand that by thinking
about the example of a heat generating
sphere in an infinite medium
so if we zoom into this medium what we'd
see is that there are heat carriers say
phonons that are running around and
colliding with one another
and in between collisions they travel an
average distance that we call the mean
street path or lambda
and in the classical fourier's law case
that again you might see in an
undergraduate course the diameter d of
the sphere is much larger than the mean
free path lambda of these heat carriers
and so we can then use this kinetic
theory expression for thermal
conductivity k that says k equals 1 3 cv
lambda and we can use this expression
along with fourier's law to calculate
the temperature rise of the sphere
but now let's consider a different case
where we have a heap generating
nanosphere whose diameter d is much much
smaller than that mean free path lambda
it turns out that in this case which we
call a ballistic heat transfer scenario
fourier's law no longer applies and
instead we have to solve the boltzmann
transport equation in order to calculate
the temperature rise of our sphere
and in this simple case we can get an
analytical solution and it turns out
that when the sphere is much smaller
than that mean free path lambda the
temperature rise is much much larger
than what fourier's law predicts
and so we can expect that in other more
complicated nanoscale geometries and
devices we're again going to have
deviations from this classical fourier
heat transfer scenario
but we don't always know the details and
so we really need experimental tools in
order to characterize and understand
these kinds of nanoscale subcontinuum
effects
starting to think in more detail about
thermometry methods that already exist
we can divide them into two broad
categories the first of which is
non-contact optical methods
and here one example that may be quite
familiar is infrared thermal imaging and
this is a very convenient approach but
the spatial resolution of this kind of
technique is limited to about 10 microns
near room temperature due to the long
wavelength of thermal radiation
and you can do a bit better by going to
high temperatures which is something
that i've done along with some
collaborators previously
but even at 3000 kelvin your spatial
resolution is still limited to about a
micron and so you just cannot get the
resolution that you need in order to
measure nanoscale hot spots
there are also many laser-based
techniques uh one common example here is
thermal reflectance techniques that use
the temperature dependent optical
reflectivity of a thin metal transducer
layer
for thermometry and here you can get
spatial resolution down to a few hundred
nanometers so that's a very fundamental
limit due to optical diffraction
and so to get the spatial resolution
that we need to measure nanoscale
hotspots we might instead think about
contact-based techniques for example
scanning probe techniques that
essentially use a modified afm tip as a
nanoscale from a couple
and here you can get quite good spatial
resolution but the challenge is that the
probe can act as a parasitic heat sink
and introduce unknown thermal contact
resistances and so it can be very
difficult to accurately extract the true
temperature of the sample that you're
measuring
uh that said as convenient as the
non-contact techniques are they are
fundamentally diffraction limited as i
mentioned
and so the question that we like to ask
in my group is
is there some way that we can still use
far-field optics but somehow beat the
diffraction limit in order to measure
the temperature of nanoscale hotspots
and so there's a number of ways that we
try to do that and one possibility and
the one that i'll focus on today
is that of using a single nanoparticle
with temperature dependent luminescence
in order to measure the temperature of
these nanoscale hotspots
basic idea is that we take a single
nanoparticle
we place it on some sample of interest
we use a laser to excite the
nanoparticle
and then we measure the temperature
dependent luminescence emitted by the
nanoparticle in order to determine the
temperature of our sample
the idea here is that the nanoparticle
is very small in an excellent thermal
contact with the sample such that it
accurately reports the true temperature
of the sample
and now i just want to drill in for a
moment on how we're getting nano scale
temperature information even though
we're using a diffraction limited laser
and so it's true that the diameter of
our excitation laser beam is indeed
diffraction limited
but the key is that if we are only
exciting a single nanoparticle
then we know that the temperature
information comes only from the
nanoparticle luminescence and therefore
the spatial resolution of the
temperature measurement is governed by
our nanoparticle size rather than the
diffraction one of the laser spots
and so when we perform our experiments
we ensure that the nanoparticles are
spaced sufficiently far apart on average
such that their diffraction limited
emission spots don't overlap
and so what that means is that we can't
math temperature with this approach but
we can get really excellent single point
temperature measurements and that's
exactly what we need for these nanoscale
hotspot applications
and so going forward i'll talk about
these specific nanoparticles
that we use the thermometry signals that
we've applied
and finally how we're able to place a
single nanoparticle at the exact
location where we want to measure the
temperature
and these are all important steps
towards actually measuring the
temperature
of one of these nanoscale hot spots like
the hammer peg which was a motivating
application for much of this work
so next we'll talk about the specific
type of nanoparticles that we use and
how we perform our temperature
measurements
we work with what are known as up
converting nanoparticles and there are
many different types but they all
typically consist of a fluoride or an
oxide host matrix doped with a
combination of lanthanide ions
the canonical upconverting nanoparticle
composition and the one that we use
quite frequently is a sodium atrium
fluoride host dosed with a combination
of ytterbium and erbium ions
they're called up converting because the
sensitizer ion which in this case is the
ytterbium absorbs two low-energy
near-infrared photons transfers this
energy to the erbium which finally emits
a single photon and the visible
wavelength range
and these upconverting nanoparticles or
ucnp's have a lot of advantages that
make them popular for a variety of
imaging and sensing applications
one advantage is that they're extremely
photos stable so they don't photo bleach
or blink
bleaching and blinking are big problems
for some probes like quantum dots so
ucnp's are an appealing alternative
ucnp's are also easy to synthesize using
high throughput combinatorial methods
they're also highly tunable so just by
swapping out one dopant for another or
changing the dopant concentration you
can get a big variation in parameters
like emission wavelengths
and finally ucnp's are highly
biocompatible in part because many of
them are excited in the first or second
biological windows which are regions
where tissue is relatively transparent
and so for this reason the bioimaging
community has led a lot of their
development
but the reason that we're interested in
ucnp's is that they have a particular
temperature dependent emission feature
so as i mentioned a moment ago the up
conversion process begins when the
ytterbium absorbs two near-infrared
photons and then transfers this energy
uh to the erbium
next the erbium decays non-radiatively
to a lower energy excited state before
returning to the ground state by
emitting a single green photon
this is clearly a complicated system
with many different energy levels and
transitions
but we can really understand the basic
temperature dependent physics by
considering a simple three level diagram
for erbium
so what you see here is erbium's ground
state along with two higher energy
thermally coupled excited states from
which the erbium can return to the
ground state by emitting a green photon
and the key is that the relative
population of these two excited states
is governed by boltzmann statistics and
that's fundamentally where our
temperature dependent signal comes from
the relative
populations of these two excited states
it turns out are directly related to the
emission intensities
from the two corresponding transitions
and we can see that by looking at single
particle spectra taken at different
temperatures
so if we divide the emission wavelength
range into two bands lambda 1 to lambda
2 and lambda 2 to lambda 3
we see that when we increase the
temperature
the emission intensity from this first
wavelength band which corresponds to the
transition from the higher energy
excited state to the ground state
increases relative to the emission
intensity from the second band which
corresponds to the transition from the
lower energy excited state to the ground
state
we can then define a temperature
dependent ratio as the integrated
emission intensity from the first
wavelength band divided by the
integrated intensity from the second
band
and this is an approach known as
ratiometric thermometry
it's been used quite commonly for
ensembles or large groups of these
upconverting nanoparticles but prior to
our work a single nanoparticle
measurements were quite rare and there
were none that use single particles
under 50 nanometers
next i'll just discuss briefly how we
perform these measurements and then show
some of the results
so we perform these measurements using a
custom scanning confocal microscopy
system and we begin by focusing a
near-infrared laser using a high n a
objective and this focused laser beam
then excites a single nanoparticle which
sits on both a
piezo control nano positioning stage and
a temperature controlled thermal stage
we then collect the emitted luminescence
filter out any residual excitation light
and then we can send that emitted
luminescence either to an avalanche
photodiode for imaging or to a
spectrometer with a ccd camera
and so here's an image of a
microscopy system that we constructed
here in my lab at the university of
rochester
this plot shows the ratio as a function
of temperature for five individual 20 by
40 nanometer
particles which were confirmed to be
single particles using sem imaging
we can see that the temperature
sensitivity of this technique is quite
good about 1500 ppm per kelvin and
there's also an excellent particle to
particle uniformity which you can see
from the nearly overlapping calibration
curves four or five different particles
and just for perspective
again this was the first time that
particles below 50 nanometers have been
used for thermometry and this is about
20x smaller than the
previously smallest
single particles that had been used for
isolated single particle measurements
like we're doing and about 5x smaller
than the
smallest single particle measurements
for a particle that was attached to an
afm tip and so this really represents a
significant improvement in terms of the
spatial resolution of this technique
all right so next i'll talk about what
began as an effort to answer the common
and important question of whether our
excitation laser could be
heating the nanoparticles but it
ultimately
morphed into a more complicated story
that led us to uncover some important
effects that occur when you excise these
nanoparticles at very high excitation
intensities
which has some important practical
uh
impacts in terms of this thermometry
technique
so if we look at the literature data for
nanoparticle ensembles it's been shown
that this temperature dependent ratio is
essentially independent of excitation
intensity
but because single nanoparticle
measurements are as i said much more
rare there haven't been the same kinds
of systematic studies looking at how the
ratio varies with intensity
but if we look at the typical excitation
intensity is required for single
nanoparticles versus unsaw bulbs
we see that they're quite different
so specifically single nanoparticles
require much higher excitation
intensities by several orders of
magnitude
and so it's been natural to ask could
these high excitation intensities
required for single nanoparticles affect
this ratiometric thermometry signal
and here i want to discuss two different
possibilities
so one possibility is that the high
excitation intensity could increase the
temperature
um
of the nanoparticle which is what we
refer to as self-heating
the second possibility is that the high
excitation intensity could distort the
boltzmann population distribution
that our ratiometric thermometry
technique relies on even though the
nanoparticle temperature hasn't changed
and so the second case uh seemed
unlikely uh based on the precedent in
the literature and so we began by
looking into this first case to see if
the high laser excitation intensities
could be heating the nanoparticle
and so we begin by first making what i
call a worst case
scenario estimate so in other words an
estimate of the highest possible
temperature rise that we could expect
for our nanoparticles and i'll
illustrate that by building up a thermal
circuit here
so we start by assuming that all of the
laser light absorbed by the nanoparticle
is converted to heat although in reality
a small amount is up converted to higher
energy light
and we calculate the absorption
cross-section based on the well-known
cross-section for eterbium ions which
are the primary absorbers of the 980
nanometer excitation light
and then this heat can either be
dissipated on the um error side
which we represent uh let's see so sorry
shown here is the substrate side
so on the substrate side we represent
that with two different thermal
resistors one representing the thermal
contact resistance between the
nanoparticle and the substrate and then
another resistor representing the
substrate thermal resistance
and then our other parallel
path is that heat could be dissipated on
the air side which we represent with
this thermal resistor our air
so again we want the worst case scenario
the highest possible temperature rise
that we could expect for this
nanoparticle
and so to get that what we do is we
ignore the substrate size thermal
resistors and we only consider our air
um and so this isn't necessarily the
most realistic scenario in fact based on
our estimates of the magnitudes of these
resistors we expect that a lot of the
heat actually will flow through the
substrate side
but it is the most conservative the
reason for that is that our air is the
largest thermal resistor and so if we
only allow the heat to flow out of the
particle through the air that will give
us the highest possible temperature rise
we could expect
and so for a 50 nanometer particle which
corresponds to those that we use in this
next set of experiments we calculate a
value of about two times ten to the nine
kelvins per watt for our air
and i'll refer to this value as our
model from here on out
and for an excitation intensity of 3
times 10 to the 5 watts per centimeter
squared which corresponds to the upper
end of the range that we use in this
next set of experiments
we calculate a temperature rise of about
2.1 kelvin
uh so not too bad even in this worst
case scenario estimate we're only
getting a few kelvin temperature rise
um and finally just to familiarize you
with a format that i'll be using
repeatedly in this next section here you
see the temperature rise the function of
excitation intensity and the slope of
this line is directly related to the
thermal resistance and the y-axis here
goes up to 50 kelvin just to emphasize
that if we're interested in measuring
temperature changes on that order then
even this worst case scenario 2 kelvin
self-heating isn't a total deal breaker
however when we actually started
performing experiments where we measured
the ratio of excitation intensity
we saw something that was different than
what we expected
so here you see the ratio measured as a
function of excitation intensity
where our substrate temperature is fixed
at room temperature about 296 kelvin
and we see that as we increase the
excitation intensity that temperature
dependent ratio also increases
likewise if we park our thermal stage at
a higher temperature of 350 kelvin and
we again increase the excitation ratio
uh the excitation intensity
we once again see that this temperature
dependent ratio increases
so what we can then do is to convert
this change in the ratio with excitation
intensity to an apparent temperature
rise
and if we do that we get an apparent
temperature rise
of over 50 kelvin so much much higher
than our worst case scenario estimate of
just 2 kelvin
and from this data we can also extract
an apparent thermal resistance and when
we do that we get a value of about 6.3
times 10 to the 10 kelvins per watt
so again more than an order of magnitude
higher than the worst case scenario
modeled value
and so it's really this dramatic
discrepancy between model and experiment
that's motivated the next set of
experiments we performed to try and
answer the question of could the
nanoparticle really be heating and if so
how can we explain this
so after observing this unexpectedly
large apparent temperature rise one of
our first thoughts was to next try to
use a second thermometry method
to verify
uh this large temperature rise and so
for the sake of time i won't go into
details but we developed a second
thermometry method based on the
temperature dependent luminescence
lifetime of these nanoparticles
and so we use this method to once again
measure the apparent temperature rise as
a function of excitation intensity
and once again we got a quite large
apparent temperature rise of somewhere
around 50 kelvin and so the second
thermometry method seemed to confirm
that the nanoparticle was perhaps
heating up by
you know far more than our conservative
model i would have suggested
and we can also extract an apparent
thermal resistance from the
lifetime thermometry method and it's
similar to the value that we got from
our original ratio metric thermometry
measurements
now one thing that these two experiments
both have in common is that the only
parameter we're varying is the
excitation intensity
and there are scenarios we can imagine
for example if we were really off in
terms of our
estimate of the absorption cross-section
where the temperature rise
that we estimate would also be quite
lost
but even if our estimates for the
magnitude of the temperature rise were
totally incorrect
if we started somehow changing these
thermal resistors
so somehow manipulating the thermal
environment surrounding the nanoparticle
this would have to have a noticeable
impact on any true temperature rise
and so that's what we did next
we started by repeating our measurements
on three different ir transparent
substrates with thermal conductivity
spanning over two orders of magnitude
namely
a polymer glass and sapphire substrates
and when we did that we measured a
essentially identical apparent
temperature rise in all three cases
and so that told us that the substrate
thermal resistance did not seem to
affect the heat dissipation
now if you recall we actually
thought that we should expect a lot of
heat to be dissipated through the
substrate side and so next we decided to
try varying the contact resistance to
see if the enlarged thermal contact
resistance between the nanoparticle and
the substrate could be limiting the heat
dissipation
all right so to vary the thermal contact
resistances we applied five different
coatings to our samples designed to
improve the thermal coupling between the
nanoparticle and the substrate so these
coatings were spin coated and drop cast
polystyrene
we applied hsq which is a spin on glass
sweatered sao2 and finally a thomas
layer deposition of sao2
the ald in particular ensures highly
formal deposition since it uses gas
phase precursors
nonetheless we measured essentially the
same apparent temperature rise for all
these coatings
and so we concluded that the contact
resistance does not
impact the
heat dissipation
and now it turns out that if you think a
bit more carefully
uh changing the contact resistance is a
little bit complicated because doing so
actually changes the air thermal
resistance as well
so i won't go into all the details for
the sake of time
but by taking that into consideration we
were able to conclude
that none of the thermal resistors
affected the heat dissipation
so the last thing that we tried is that
we tried changing the absorption cross
section of our nanoparticles and so we
chose to do that by varying the
nanoparticle
size while keeping the concentration
of the eterbium ions constant but with a
larger size nanoparticle you get more
eterbium ions and you increase the
absorption cross-section
so what we found is that for both a 20
by 40 nanometer particle and a 50
nanometer particle we measured again the
same apparent temperature rise
and this just cannot be explained by any
heat transfer model
the reason for that is that these
temperature rise is equal to the heat
absorbed q times the thermal resistance
r
we know that q scales with the
nanoparticle diameter d cubed
and so to have
the temperature rise theta be
independent of c the thermal resistance
r would have to scale as 1 over d cubed
and so it turns out that we're right in
the middle of
being right on the border of being in a
classical fourier heat transfer regime
versus a ballistic heat transfer regime
going to something i mentioned at the
beginning
of this seminar
but in either case we can't get that one
over d cubed scaling we might be
somewhere between the one over d scaling
uh from the fourier case or one over d
squared from the ballistic case but
there's just no way that we can get that
one over d cubed scaling
and so we concluded that the absorption
cross section and the particle diameter
don't affect the heat dissipation
so just to recap what i've shown up to
this point first our worst case scenario
self-heating estimate predicted no more
than a few kelvin of heating
and then we found that the apparent
self-heating that we measured despite
being 50 kelvin or more
didn't seem to depend on any formal
parameters we tried varying all these
resistors and the absorption cross
section but saw no changes
and so at that point we really had to
ask is there any way that this effect
could in fact be non-thermal and even
though this did not seem like a strong
possibility early on at this point our
experiments clearly said that this could
not be a true temperature rise
and so my collaborators did some more
modeling to
really investigate in more detail what
might be going on
so i'm fortunate to have some great
collaborators dr emory chan lawrence
berkeley lab and dr ayala titleboyne
who was also at lawrence berkeley lab at
the time
and they've developed some very
sophisticated rate equation models um
that let them
uh
essentially calculate
all the different uh you know absorption
and transition and energy transfer and
luminescence mechanisms that are going
on in these nanoparticles
and from these calculations they're able
to actually
uh model
the ratios that we measure
uh so what you can see here is the
energy level diagram for erbium that i
showed before
and i only showed energy levels up to a
certain point because that's typically
the range that's considered important
for ratiometric thermometry
but in reality there are a whole bunch
of higher energy excited states and at
high excitation intensities these higher
energy excited states can actually
become significantly populated
and so in their models
the collaborators account for a whole
bunch of different higher energy excited
states and transitions involving those
states and so the yellow boxes that you
see in these two diagrams
enclose the thermally coupled levels
that give rise to
the emission that we use to calculate
the temperature dependent ratio and then
everything above that on the right hand
diagram
is a higher energy excited state
and so again through a detailed
accounting of all the ways in which
absorption emission
energy transfer non-radiative relaxation
and so on can occur
my collaborators are able to calculate
the ratio as a function of excitation
intensity
when they did that they found
surprisingly that their models actually
predict that the ratio will increase
with excitation intensity
uh the model values are just a bit lower
than what we measure experimentally but
we don't expect an exact quantitative
match since these models use many
semi-empirical parameters
so we can then do is to plot the
relative increase and the modeled ratio
values by normalizing those values with
respect to their minimum
and we can then plot analogous
experimental data
and what we see is that there's quite a
good match between the measured and
modeled a relative increase in the ratio
and so again i'll just emphasize that
there are no free parameters that we use
to get this match between the measured
and modeled relative increase in this
ratio
uh finally by looking at the modeling
results in a bit more detail
we see that it's a combination
of
radiative and non-radiative relaxation
from higher energy excited states in
erbium that distorts the boltzmann
population distribution our ratiometric
thermometry technique relies on and
increases the ratio
and so of course it's important to be
aware of this kind of non-thermal change
on the ratio but once we really
understand this kind of effect in detail
we can calibrate it or work at low
excitation intensities and still use
this technique as a way to measure
nanoscale hotspots
lastly just to really confirm
that this effect was truly non-thermal
we did some final experiments where we
coated
some glass
samples substrates with a thin layer of
platinum and then placed nanoparticles
on these samples
the reason to do that is that the
platinum which is pretty absorptive in
the near ir
will therefore absorb a decent amount of
the laser light but then we have this
low thermal conductivity glass layer
underneath
that really
is not a good heat dissipator and so
what that means is that we can get a
temperature rise of
hundreds of degrees when we
shine a laser onto this type of sample
so what we did is we first started out
by using just a plain glass sample so no
platinum on this one and we measure the
ratio as a function of excitation
intensity and unsurprisingly we see an
increase in the ratio and that's this
apparent self-heating effect that i just
talked about
um and then if we repeat this
measurement with a nanoparticle on
platinum coated glass
then what happens is we get a much much
steeper increase in the ratio indicative
of true laser heating on top of this
apparent self-heating effect
and we also lose the signal from the
nanoparticle at certain points in terms
of increasing the excitation intensity
and that's consistent with other reports
in the literature as these nanoparticles
degrade around 600 kelvin or so
we then repeated this experiment
for
diamond substrates which has a much much
higher thermal conductivity by orders of
magnitude
and here we see that the results are the
same whether it's for a nanoparticle on
their glass bare diamond or platinum
coated diamond and so that makes sense
for a non-thermal
effect because in all those cases
there is no heating going on and this
increase in the ratio of excitation
intensity is a purely non-thermal effect
lastly before wrapping up here i just
want to answer the question of how we're
able to take a single one of these
nanoparticles and place it at the exact
location on the sample where we want to
measure temperature that's of course
very critical because if we don't have a
way to do that then this whole technique
really falls apart
and so the approach that we take here is
that we use an atomic force microscope
tip or afn tip
to push individual nanoparticles around
substrates and place them at the
location where we'd like to measure
temperature
so the way that we do that and a lot of
this work right now is being done by my
graduate student dinesh committee
is that we essentially hack the nano
lithography mode on our park nx10 afm
and then we use that to position
individual nanoparticles uh on various
solid substrates
and so the examples that i'll show here
are for
individual
nanodiamonds
that are about 100 nanometers or even
less in diameter but again we apply this
technique quite broadly to all kinds of
nanoparticles
uh so we can do both microscale
manipulation which is how dinesh made
this r for rochester that you see shown
here
and then we can also do finer movements
so here's an example where we move one
particle with respect to another
by about 95 nanometers
and then here's another example of
moving a single particle by just about
20 nanometers so this provides a
powerful way to place single
nanoparticles exactly where we want to
perform our temperature measurements
so to wrap up in my group we really
focus on pushing the boundaries of
far-field optical nanothermometry
uh in the past we've done a lot of work
on using individual upconverting
nanoparticles for sub 50 nanometer
single point thermometry and that's
really the majority of the work that i
talked about today
uh and then we have some other projects
in slightly different directions at the
moment
finally i'd like to acknowledge uh past
funding support from uc berkeley and the
nsf
uh the molecular foundry at lawrence
berkeley lab and seagate and then
current funding support from the
university of rochester and the american
chemical society petroleum research fund
um if you're interested in learning more
please feel free to visit our website
listed here at the bottom of the slide
and then with that i'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you andrea for your informative
presentation we'll now start the live q
a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started
our first question
um how do the up converting
nanoparticles compare to other
fluorescent therm thermometers
uh sure so that's a great question
because certainly these upconverting
nanoparticles are not the only types of
luminescent materials that have been
used for thermometry
there's a lot of things like fluorescent
dyes proteins that have been used for
thermometry as well as other inorganic
materials
so for example nitrogen vacancy centers
and nanodiamonds and we work with some
of these other materials as well
so i think some of the major advantages
of the upconverting nanoparticle would
be first of all they're just extremely
uniform
and i talked about that a bit when i
showed some of these ratio metric
thermometry's results for different
individual particles and you see that
these calibration curves are really
uniform
from one particle to another so that's a
big advantage in terms of being able to
do say a batch calibration where you
calibrate a small number of single
particles
from a batch and then you can go on and
apply that calibration to a totally
different nanoparticle from that same
batch
so that's one big advantage
another
aspect that i'd highlight is
because you excite these upconverted
nanoparticles in the near ir but then
they emit
hundreds of nanometers away in the
visible wavelength range that can be a
big advantage if you're trying to avoid
a spectral overlap with some other kind
of signal
and that's such a huge anti-stokes shift
that you really don't get from a lot of
other types of materials
and so that can be
you know a unique advantage as well
thank you for that andreas our next
question
if you were to use a single up
converting nanoparticle as a thermometer
in a plasmonic environment such as the
hammer hard drive we mentioned would you
expect expect this plasmonic environment
to change the ratiometric thermometry
signal
sure so yeah that's an important
question right because we know that for
something like that hammer hard drive
application you're going to need to
put these nanoparticles in a very
intense plasmonic environment and it's
definitely reasonable
to worry that you know perhaps this
plasmonic environment could change the
temperature dependent luminescence
signal
and so one thing that's helpful is that
there are other people who have already
used these upconverting nanoparticles
for thermometry in plasmonic
environments
and they actually see that
the ratio values that you get as a
function of temperature
are extremely similar to what you get in
more of a conventional non-plasmonic
environment
so that's kind of a helpful precedent
there
you get some enhancement in the overall
brightness which is actually
a big advantage perhaps but you don't
see distortions
of the ratio
the other thing that can be helpful and
this goes back to what i was saying
previously about having this advantage
of a large separation between
the excitation wavelength and the
emission wavelength and then also the
fact that these wavelengths are just
very tunable
uh by changing these lanthanide dopants
is that you can
basically ensure that your excitation
wavelengths and your emission
wavelengths are both not anywhere near
the plasmonic resonance
and so that's something that you know we
were thinking about when we selected the
particular nanoparticles that we use for
this work in order to try and avoid
any interference with that plasmonic
aspect of these hammer drives
great thank you looks like we have time
for one more question what are some
potential ways to mitigate the
non-thermal excite excitation intensity
artifacts that you discussed and what
are the broader implications of this
type of artifact
sure um
right so as i talked about during the
presentation you know these excitation
intensity artifacts if you're not aware
of them can potentially uh really
distort your temperature measurements
which is of course
not ideal
so i think there are a few ways that you
can get around it so
one is just to work at a fixed
excitation intensity rate so if you can
stay at a stable excitation intensity
value throughout your measurements
then you're not going to have to worry
about these kinds of effects showing up
a kind of similar idea is to work at low
excitation intensities where even their
small changes in the excitation
intensity will not give you this big
apparent temperature change so that's
another way
um to avoid these effects
but then even if you're in a situation
where you know you need to work at
higher excitation intensities and
perhaps you cannot guarantee that the
excitation intensity is held constant uh
just being aware of these effects you
can calibrate them you know by doing the
excitation intensity sweeps um that we
did
and then you know take that into account
so that you understand what is really a
temperature change and what is this kind
of non-thermal um artifact
um so in terms of you know broader
implications i think that it's something
to consider in the context of libsyn's
nanothermometry more broadly which as i
mentioned if you know you know a lot of
people
are using uh with many different
materials which is great uh certainly i
think it's a really powerful
technique you know at the same time it's
important to be aware that many of these
signals that have been identified as
temperature dependent uh can also change
due to other parameters you know whether
it's something like excitation intensity
or
you know things like pressure for
example
uh there's a lot of reasons these
signals can change and so i think just
doing these very careful experiments
to really tease out what are temperature
changes what is something else
is probably important more broadly for
the field of fluorescence thermometry
thank you again andrea for your time
today and your important research we'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor andor for writing underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
any questions we do not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues and anyone who have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye